[Música]
la tan anunciada contra ofensiva
ucraniana de primavera contra las zonas
del este del país ocupadas por Rusia
Siguen sin materializarse ahora sin
embargo las declaraciones de bolodimio
zeledsky y suministro de defensa así
como nuevos movimientos de tropas y
armamento hacen pensar que la operación
no puede estar cerca se les habla
incluso de recuperar crimea y el jefe
del grupo paramilitar ruso Wagner avisa
al kremlin si no hay mayor envío de
municiones las consecuencias pueden ser
desastrosas para Moscú vamos a analizar
este tema y para ello hemos invitado a
Nuño Rodríguez él es experto en
geopolítica y estrategia analista de
Quijote glow Muchísimas gracias Nuño por
estar con nosotros
Hola muy buenas tardes Mire durante la
batalla por mahmud se hablaba de la
falta de munición en kiev las nuevas
ayudas de los aliados Usted cree que ya
permitirán llevar a cabo la
contraofensiva o todavía es incierta la
capacidad militar ucraniana hemos visto
la llegada de armamento Durante los
últimos meses con mucha más fuerza
Ucrania en teoría tiene armamento de
sobra para hacer una contraofensiva y
para hacer las labores de defensa y
defensiva que estimación oportunas en
teoría lleva recibiendo fondos lleva
recibiendo municiones lleva recibiendo
material de muy diverso uso pues Durante
un año en los últimos meses se ha
incrementado considerablemente todas
toda la cantidad de ayuda que estaba
recibiendo pero lo que viene siendo
medios materiales no deberían de ser una
una excusa Y en este sentido sí que
estamos viendo que diversos
dirigentes políticos nos están diciendo
que les falta munición que le sigue
faltando algún tipo de material ofensivo
que les falta Aviación no sabemos si es
un estratagema un modo de engañar a
través de las fuentes abiertas al
ejército ruso Pero lo que sí que sabemos
es que se debería de hacer algo en este
sentido todo el mundo está esperando
Incluso el ministro de defensa sabe
perfectamente que si no dan un golpe de
efecto van a dejar de recibir ayuda los
países occidentales todo el mundo está
esperando recuperar su inversión todo
esto que se le ha dado a Ucrania no era
una donación
sin retorno se espera que haya un
retorno de la inversión como en
cualquier otro negocio que al final es
lo que está haciendo esto Qué es lo que
está sucediendo habrá que ver si lo que
quiere Ucrania es recuperar territorios
y lo que quiere es conseguir expulsar
las tropas rusas del territorio que
ahora mismo es Rusia administrativamente
ya están todos los ciudadanos con pasar
Ruso y todos los coches con placas rusas
O qué es lo que quiere Ucrania quiere
seguir recibiendo fondos quiere
recuperar territorios quiere dar un
golpe de efecto Qué es lo que está
buscando cuando no sabes cuál es la
estrategia que puede llegar a tener un
oponente siempre se supone que la
estrategia mínima que puede llegar a
tener es la de supervivencia
Y en este momento el status quo es que
está teniendo el ejército ucraniano y
todos sus dirigentes políticos es muy
cómodo están recibiendo fondos sin
contrapartida y Bueno hay una línea
proporcional entre los fondos que se
están recibiendo en Ucrania y las
mansiones que los ucranianos están
comprando en el Mediterráneo europeo
bueno eso habría que analizarlo habría
que verlo no por supuesto por otro lado
usted estaba hablando de cómo sería esa
ofensiva en qué se concentraría Ucrania
en esta nueva etapa que se abre de la
guerra que ya lleva más de un año de
duración no se conocen efectivamente
detalles de los planes ucranianos pero
sí se habla de una posible ofensiva
sobre saporilla o incluso de llegar
hasta crimea tácticamente pues Usted qué
opina cuál sería el mejor plan o por
dónde languidece más el frente de guerra
ruso
hay que tener en cuenta que de una
manera estratégica si consideramos que
lo que está buscando Ucrania es
recuperar todos los territorios sobre
los que ahora mismo se asiente a Rusia
Pues sí que tendría que hacer una
entradilla sobre la sección de saporinha
para poder cortar todos los suministros
que le pueden llegar a Rusia en vía
terrestre desde desde el territorio de
la gran Rusia en este sentido sí que
sería una estrategia primaria sería uno
un primer avance nada más lo único que
mantener ahí un corredor de ruptura
entre entre los diferentes bandos que
Rusia está controlando sería bastante
complicado y ahora mismo No creo yo que
Ucrania sola con sin la ayuda directa no
indirecta con ayuda sin ayuda directa de
ejércitos de la otan pueda llegar a
mantener un corredor que rompa la vía de
suministros del ejército ruso en todas
las regiones
mire justamente hoy salieron datos de
los supuestos fallecimientos de soldados
de parte y parte Durante este poco más
de un año de guerra lanzando un mensaje
de desgaste no hacia el otro ejército si
quieres lanza esta nueva ofensiva y si
no tiene el éxito esperado Usted cree
que esto podría mirar el conflicto más
hacia un tema de diálogo y finalmente de
final de finalización de los
enfrentamientos bélicos
me gustaría que fuese así de hecho me
gustaría que hubiese sido así desde un
principio uno de los principales
problemas a los que nos encontramos
todos los analistas de geopolítica o por
lo menos alguno que tenemos un mínimo de
ética dentro de estos asuntos es que
sabemos que cuando estamos hablando de
este tipo de situaciones de este tipo de
conflictos Al final todo se cristaliza
en la muerte de seres humanos en el
campo de batalla es muy bonito hablar de
estrategias de geopolíticas de grandes
políticas de Estados Pero al final lo
que se cristaliza es en huérfanos es en
viudos es en familias gotas es en
cementerios llenos de cuerpos que es lo
que está sucediendo a día de hoy y todas
las guerras al final todos los soldados
solamente hay que leer todos los diarios
de guerra de la Segunda Guerra Mundial
todos al final se acaban preguntando por
qué Por qué estábamos luchando todo al
final carece de sentido el diálogo tenía
que haber prevalecido no solo desde
desde el inicio de la guerra sino desde
el 2014 y antes del 2014 desde 1991 que
se estaban saboteando todas las líneas
de suministro de crudo de y de gas de
Rusia hacia Europa si buscamos Cuál es
el origen del conflicto nos podemos
ahondar nuestra memoria en el tiempo y
al final siempre se había necesitado
tener más diálogo haber sido más
diplomático y haber entendido más las
posturas del otro
mire por otro lado están los problemas
de abastecimiento de municiones que
enfrenta a Rusia y que se han llevado
por delante al viceministro de defensa
al jefe de Wagner que pues ha insistido
mucho en que no estamos co entregando el
armamento que ellos necesitan para
defender sus posiciones y que podría
suponer Incluso en un escenario digamos
catastrófico y extremo perder crimea
Usted cree que Rusia está realmente
preparada ahora mismo para una
contraofensiva
[Música]
no habían tenido una información
suficiente que había habido una dejadez
por parte de los responsables rusos es
muy difícil explicar todos los fallos
que ha habido tanto por un lado como por
otro De hecho es muy difícil explicar
que es lo que ha estado sucediendo
durante el terreno ya no solo por la
cantidad de por la ingente cantidad de
propaganda que ha habido por todos los
lados me hablabas del número de víctimas
el número de víctimas es increíble el
baila por todos los sitios o sea pero si
tú juntas todos los números de las
víctimas que ha habido en esta guerra
pues al final resulta que habían muerto
generaciones y generaciones que todavía
no han llegado de uno y de otro bando
explicar lo que cada bando ha hecho en
el terreno dentro de una manera racional
militar estratégica es casi imposible
pues miren Nuño ya nos quedamos sin
tiempo Yo le agradezco mucho por
entregarnos esta información es experto
en geopolítica y estrategia analista de
Quijote globos que tengo feliz día
Igualmente muchas gracias a nuestros
televidentes sigan con nosotros ya
volvemos con más titulares de directo
América
[Música]